hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to hand simulator
survival now that I don't have beavis
and butt-head next to me making
everything worse and the genius can
execute his genius vision of survival on
this island the said genius who is me
Lexi and point out who the genius is in
this endeavor thanks buddy so I'm gonna
go out on this island and I am going to
survive all by myself because I won't
have to share resources I'll have to do
a little bit more scavenging I get that
I know that
however with those other idiots not
holding me back I am gonna be in great
shape to show the world just how good I
am at surviving in survival situations
yes it is markiplier time so my first
step is to proclaim my glory to the
world
yay I'm awesome alright did it the
second step is to start gathering up
sticks
grab yep oh god I forgot how to play
there we go okay I have not forgotten
how to play that is that is a ruse
that's a lie that's definitely a lie I
definitely remember how to play and in
doing so I have sticks okay so what I
need to remember is that I'm a genius
and everything I do is awesome now that
we got that cleared out of the way just
gotta get back to the basics
cuz the problem before is we didn't have
enough for everyone to survive the night
but I am the genius so I'm gonna make
sure that I have enough to survive the
night priority being cocoanuts rocks no
I got rocks you only really need one
rock right I think I have no idea and
then figure out what the hell to do with
logs because I know I know there's got
to be I know there's got to be like some
greater meaning to logs but I just got
to find out what that actually is
because there's got to be like a way to
make a bonfire
least like a signal fire because that's
what the likely probability is it's
going to be like some kind of a signal
fire that's gonna be big enough that
everyone's gonna be able to see it and
that is what's going to get us in in the
survival situation okay more sticks
we just need doodles and noodles of
sticks more sticks than you could shake
a stick at
funny joke me thanks I'm all alone on
the island
no one's here to be by my side I can
make friends on the island there's a
lovely
tiger somewhere here who I'm willing to
bet would be my friend if they just knew
how number one handsome number two
awesome I am or I can create a spear
that I can use to shift said tiger when
tiger is going to the bathroom or
generally not looking which would be a
better opportunity than my original idea
because on the genius who knows no
limits right Lexia you're here with me
to write you an you and me no one else
in you and me oh what a fun day I'm glad
that I was trapped on this island all
alone and all my friends died in that
boat I'm glad that they didn't get out
in time that I'm out here all by myself
I'm glad that I was the one to jump off
the boat first because I could tell that
things were going wrong and the boat
definitely isn't still floating out here
and I didn't wash up on this island all
by myself because I'm just an idiot and
preemptively went off the boat that'd be
insane that would probably break
someone's mind if that actually was the
case which it's not
[Music]
it definitely is not the case now
that boat was sinking I saw the smoke
coming out of those big tubes at the top
of the boat yeah and where there's smoke
there's fire and if there's fire and a
boat a lot people die I know that man
there was like there was like three
tubes that were just billowing smoke out
of them I think those were like the air
filtration system trying to get fresh
air down to the lower decks you know
where the the scuzz are not like me nose
up top
oh my poor friends you know not
literally poor as in pity them and
Porras and not know money like they they
were down way below they're definitely
they definitely did not survive the fire
because those pipes I believe goes
straight to the lower decks and if that
happened that they are goners and I am
sad that they are not with us anymore
man afternoon already time sure flies
when you're having fun right legs Ian ah
you yeah with all your jokes God that
yours though silly silly silly silly
Portuguese man alright okay I'm gonna
make sure all my wood doesn't actually
burn up in one big gush so I'm gonna try
to keep two different piles so I don't
lose everything all at once I'm gonna
need some cocoa nut to keep me cocoa
healthy and do using wanted this yeah I
did it
thanks for the raucous applause there
Lix Ian you're always on my side thick
and thin that's what you that's what you
are thick and thin
alright eat oh so much better mmm good
stuff this is what they call the good
stuff yummy okay all right okay good
good stuff sure wish I knew how to craft
not that anyone else that I may or may
not have been on this island with new
out of craft not not where the damn let
me tell you me all I got to do is apply
my big beefy brain to it now be good so
all I gotta do right now is that gonna
make sure I have enough sticks to last
the night because I've made the mistake
with some company who shall not ever be
named that we didn't have enough
firewood so all I gotta do is make sure
we have enough firewood right yeah I
agree
I agree wholeheartedly with you with
what you just said I am smart I am happy
I am a good survivor I am so smart and
handsome and dance thank you I know
right
I really should have won most handsome
man before I got trapped on an island
that is an injustice that I did not win
you're correct
who's getting dark I'd better get a fire
going hope I got enough wood maybe I
don't know all right I need one more
rock to be able to make sparks I saw
ones over here good all right and grab
and up and go and perfect so I don't
need to do this until it starts the
until the temperature starts dropping
because I think that was a mistake
before only need to do it when the temp
starts dropping I don't think we need to
have all of this wood here right away
probably the bigger pieces of wood we
want to keep just because those are
gonna burn the longest or maybe a
mixture of the two I don't know oh [ __ ]
okay temperature is starting to drop all
right let's get this fire going with
what we have right here let me just
adjust this BAM adjust adjust according
a just adjust accordingly
adjust adjust adjust accordingly
all right we didn't need that one anyway
okay right hand left hand right hand
left hand right hand left hand right
hand left hand no grab perfect how or
how
whoa hahaha
that just goes that really just goes for
it
okay I'm gonna crack open another one of
these bad boys okay I'm gonna drop these
down grab up one of these can you cook
coconut there's the boat but you know we
don't need it
boats are for chumps and losers I am
neither a chump nor loser I am a smart
and a cool guy so cool oh okay that one
looks done yum yum yum who it was that
any better I have no idea if that
actually did anything if I could have it
they'd be great no stop getting in the
stop stop getting it stop stop stop
get who got this in here in my mouth
YUM delicious and that that must have
been cooked because it was less juicy
I've got less thirst quenched from that
so what I need is now to complement it
with one of these and get some thirst
quenched right I hear you go away I
don't have what I need to be able to
solve you so screw off okay cram grab
you want one lick see it all for me oh
you're so so we offer me I do have to
keep up buying credible muscle mass what
was that wait what happened
why can't I wait I can't move what
happened what
[Music]
I did it I did it I did it
I'm a genius I'm literally the best I am
the best I want to thank my mom mom if
you're watching this I did this for you
I want to thank my cousin's young BAE
guy he's an actor in South Korea's
really going up in the world I believe
in him so strongly and he believes in me
or if they hate me or to think lik Seon
lissa flick see I'm gonna have to leave
you behind now my career is taking off
right now I am obviously the best and I
listen it I don't want to hold you back
that's what it I want you to be able I'm
finding success now now you need to find
success so you roll on out of here yeah
alright see oh that's cute okay bye
I accept this award of being great
survivor in the history of hen simulator
survival I accept it with open arms and
even open earth eyes this is incredible
thank you and thank you everybody so
much for watching I don't you know it's
it's just a testament to how genius I
actually am that I'm not a hundred
percent sure what I did to get the
victory that I did
that's just how in ain't my intelligence
is thank you everybody so much for
believing in me and believing in me even
now I know you're liking like you've
never liked before I know you're lining
up to subscribe and are inherently
breaking YouTube because so many people
are trying to subscribe and ring that
Bell simultaneously please have patience
the button even though you're breaking
it right now by clicking it so many
times
understand you will get your
subscription in I promise you that the
likes they will go through the numbers
no one's ever seen the numbers that
we're seeing right now but just
understand I appreciate this and I
appreciate you so thank you everybody so
much for watching and keep trying it'll
go through I promise you that just keep
smashing that subscribe button as hard
as you can
it'll go through
so thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye are you
[Music]